einen schönen guten morgen wir melden
uns mit zdf heute live nach einem
spannenden abend im
us-präsidentschaftswahlkampf
beziehungsweise einer spannenden 8 aus
deutscher sicht denn um 3 uhr unserer
zeit sind die beiden kandidaten für das
vize präsidentenamt angetreten im tv
duell der republikanische amtsinhaber
und seine demokratische herausforderung
fahrer herausforderin kerbela harris
senatorin harris es ist ein privileg mit
ihnen auf einer bühne zu sein
schon bei diesen ersten sekunden deutete
sich an dieses duell würde vollkommen
anders verlaufen als das erste tv-duell
der präsidentschaftskandidaten donald
trump und joe biden hatten sie ja nichts
geschenkt es war eine absolut chaotische
debatte inhalte zählten da nur wenig das
war heute nacht komplett anders das kann
ich jetzt schon mal sagen und auch unser
korrespondent hat natürlich die debatte
minuziös beobachtet el mati wissen in
washington muss jetzt tief in der nacht
bis guten morgen helmer guten morgen
keine silbe
wie würdest du denn diese debatte auf
den punkt bringen wie hast du sie erlebt
also es war eine debatte ohne große
highlights ist wurde scharf in der sache
gestritten aber vor allen dingen
zivilisiert und das war der
entscheidende unterschied zu der debatte
vor einer woche eigentlich atmen hier
alle ein stück weit auf weil man hat
gehofft dass es wirklich mehr um die
inhalte geht es ging dann auch
tatsächlich um die inhalte die beiden
waren recht freundlich zueinander
allerdings ist mike pence kamera harris
deutlich häufiger ins wort gefallen oder
hat seine redezeit deutlich häufiger
überzogen als kammerherr ist die das
auch hin und wieder getan hat und die
moderatorin hatte es an einigen stellen
doch auch wieder etwas schwer dafür zu
sorgen dass die disziplin eingehalten
wird
danke emma wir werden gleich noch viel
wir sprechen miteinander über siege über
meine fragen sondern auch über eure
fragen liebe user bitte schreibt uns was
ihr wissen wollt von unserem
korrespondenten was wir besprechen
sollen per e mail unter zdf heute - live
at zdf de
unterdessen schauen wir uns aber erstmal
in der übersicht an was die amerikaner
90 minuten lang zu sehen bekam britta
jäger hat die zusammenfassung auftritt
der zweite vizepräsident mike pence
duelliert sich mit seiner demokratischen
herausforderin calama harris mit
dreieinhalb meter abstand und durch
plexiglas scheiben strengere
vorsichtsmaßnahmen nachdem sich der
präsident und mehrere personen in seinem
umfeld infiziert hatten
die pandemie thema nummer eins direkt zu
beginn die amerikaner waren zeuge des
größten versagens einer administration
in der geschichte unseres landes am 28
januar wussten der vizepräsident und der
präsident über die gefahr dieser
pandemie bescheid
sie wussten es und sie haben es
verschleiert der präsident hat gesagt es
sei ein schwind bevor es mehr als fünf
fälle in den usa gab
alles leute die aus china zurück kam hat
der präsident etwas getan das keiner
zuvor getan hatte
er hat die einreise aus china gestoppt
der wahl attacken von harris immer
wieder schießt sie gegen donald trump
erwähnt die mehr als 210.000 corona
toten in den usa pence nüchterner als
sein chef der im schlagabtausch mit joe
biden für chaos sorgte er ist im
verteidigungs- modus bleibt bei den
plänen der regierung für weitere vier
jahre im ungefähren wiederholt
altbekanntes auch beim thema rassismus
und polizeigewalt unter präsident chance
führung werden wir immer hinter den
gesetzeshütern stehen das war so von tag
eins an der präsident der vereinigten
staaten hat sich bei der debatte vor 70
millionen leute gestellt und sich
geweigert weiße rechtsradikale zu
verurteilen abtreibung klimaschutz aber
auch immer wieder das thema corona und
krankenversicherung
wenn sie eine vorerkrankung haben
diabetes brustkrebs werden die bei ihnen
passieren
obama war ein desaster daran erinnern
sich die leute
sie will die erste schwarze vize
präsidentin werden er will auf seinem
posten bleiben
laut ersten umfragen sieht die mehrheit
der amerikaner kamalla harris als
siegerin
sie hat gezeigt dass sie den job kann
soweit das wichtigste dieser debatte im
überblick wir werden das jetzt noch mal
alles aufdröseln zusammen mit unserem
usa-korrespondent negative sind in
washington
bevor wir auf die themen komm lass uns
noch mal kurz bei der debatte selbst
bleiben welche bedeutung hat jesus duell
im us-wahlkampf es war ja dieses jahr
mit sehr großem interesse verfolgt
worden
ja normalerweise sagt man bei einer vize
präsidentschafts debatte das ist so ein
bisschen die vorgruppe zum eigentlichen
konzert das dann theoretisch nächste
woche wieder wäre nämlich die zweite
debatte zwischen den
präsidentschaftskandidaten
aber diesmal war es eben anders
vielleicht historisch erstmals ist die
vize-präsidentin debatte eine
präsidentschafts debatte gewesen weil
jeder im grunde um im kopf hat dass die
beiden dran sein könnten in dem moment
wo möglicherweise donald trump oder joe
biden nicht mehr in der lage wären
präsident zu sein möglicherweise
erkrankten sterben joe biden und donald
trump wären ja jeweils bei der
vereidigung am 20 januar die ältesten
präsidenten dies hier in der us
geschichte gegeben hätte insofern sah
man das heute mit anderen augen und man
muss ehrlich sagen beide haben
eigentlich unterm strich eine figur eine
gute figur gemacht so dass man sagen
kann 'die können präsident wiewohl es
natürlich schon starke inhaltliche
unterschiede zwischen den beiden gab die
schauen wir uns gleich an gucken wir mal
auf das kommunikationsverhalten das ist
bei beiden komplett anders als bei den
präsidentschafts kandidaten howard es
auf kamener harris 55 jahre alt
demokraten er temperamentvoll gilt als
debatten stark wie hat sie das gezeigt
konnte sie es zeigen heute ja ich glaube
das hat sie ja eigentlich ganz gut
gezeigt sie hat ja viel erfahrung als
ehemalige staatsanwältin dann
justizministerin in kalifornien da hat
sie vor gericht als staatsanwältin ja
fälle verhandelt das heißt sie hat schon
ein stück weit auch das gespür für eine
art kreuzverhör und das hatte man gleich
am anfang
als es um das thema corona gegen da hat
sie vielleicht auch den satz des abends
gelandet wir haben vorhin einen kleinen
teil davon gehört sie hat gesagt sie
haben es gewusst damit meinte sie die
gefahr die vom corona virus ausgeht dass
ende januar schon die regierung wusste
wie gefährlich das virus ist dass es
sich durch die luft überträgt das auch
junge menschen sich anstecken können
also ihr satz sie haben es gewusst und
sie haben es ihnen und damit meinte sie
die zuschauer und hat ihren blick in die
kamera gerichtet ihnen nicht gesagt sie
haben es gewusst sie haben es vertuscht
so hat sie gesagt damit war eigentlich
mike pence von beginn an in der
defensive und er hat sicherlich auch
einige treffer dann gelandet gegen
kamera heraus zum beispiel als sie nicht
so recht wusste wie das steuerprogramm
von joe biden und camilla harris
eigentlich gemeinsam aussieht das hat
sie ein bisschen falsch dargestellt aber
insgesamt hat sie durch ihren ich sag
mal erreicht forschen stil doch mehr
punkte gemacht als mike pence der
eigentlich ja immer in der rolle war den
präsidenten verteidigen zu müssen
das tut er ja schon im grunde sind seit
immer gilt als sehr loyal gegenüber
donald trump gilt als jetzt zurückhalten
der charmante bat einige sagen sogar
schon fast wie hat er das ausgespielt
heute ja er war am anfang sehr sehr
freundlich er hat gesagt er fühlt sich
geehrt dass er mit kabel daher ist hier
auf der bühne steht hat sich auch
überall bedankt hat an mehreren stellen
auch gesagt dass er bewundert dass sie
als erste schwarze frau eben tatsächlich
jetzt auch eine chance hat vize
präsidenten amerikas zu werden
also er war sehr höflich sehr freundlich
hat sich damit deutlich unterschieden
von donald trump jetzt kommt das aber
genau wie donald trump hat an
zahlreichen stellen
ich sag's mal ganz glatt gelogen und das
kann man dieses mal wirklich nachweisen
in der debatte in der letzten woche gab
es ja in erster linie beschimpfungen wie
kann man nicht fakt checken
aber man kann natürlich inhaltliche
diskussionen fakt checken und da muss
man ganz klar sagen dass an mehreren
stellen mike bands schlicht und
ergreifend die version seines ich sag's
mal überspitzt meisters des
amerikanischen präsidenten übernommen
hat und damit weiterhin
gegen verbreitet hat ein freund hat
pence gemacht in der debatte eine fliege
hat sich auf seinen kopf gesetzt wird
auch bei uns bei den usern breit
diskutiert das schreibt zum beispiel
horst heldt das fliegen orakel hat
gesprochen pence bleibt vizepräsident
immer du hast schon eben gesagt die
angriffe zum beispiel in sachen corona
pandemie die gegenseitigen das war eines
der beherrschenden themen es war das
erste thema das angesprochen wurde und
wir schauen mal gemeinsam rein was pence
und herres dazu zu sagen
das amerikanische volk hat den größten
misserfolg einer präsidentschaft
miterlebt den es jemals in der
geschichte unseres landes gab präsident
ich vertrauen dem amerikanischen volk
selbst entscheidungen zu treffen im
interesse ihrer gesundheit joe biden und
kämmerer harris reden ständig über
regierungs befugnisse und nicht nur was
das corona virus angeht sie wollen die
kontrolle über gesundheit einen green
deal überall regierungskontrolle
uns geht es um freiheit und darum die
freiheit des amerikanischen volkes zu
respektieren
reden wir über respekt sie zeigen
respekt wenn sie den amerikanern die
wahrheit sagen
gerade wenn es um dinge geht die sie den
menschen nicht sagen wollen die die
menschen aber hören müssen und sich
selbst zu schützen
ja das sind die ersten einblicke die uns
übrigens auch zeigen beide kandidaten
waren durch plexiglas scheiben getrennt
eine maßnahme die man eingeführt hat
wahrscheinlich nicht ohne auch auf die
korona auf die wir keine infektionen von
us-präsident am zuschauern ma 210.000
corona tote in den usa überschritten
mehr als siebeneinhalb millionen
infizierte bisher insgesamt das ist die
lage vor diesem hintergrund wurde das
thema diskutiert wie wurde es diskutiert
über das hinaus was wir gerade schon
gehört haben
ja ich glaube es ist der wunde punkt der
administration den teil den wir vorhin
gehört haben der hatte auch damit zu tun
dass gefragt wurde
die kann man eigentlich vertreten was da
im weißen haus passiert ist im
rosengarten gewissermaßen das super
special event bei dem sich zahlreiche
menschen ganz offenbar infiziert haben
weil keine maske getragen wurde
weil man sich umarmt und geherzt hatte
zur begrüßung und daraufhin daneben die
antwort von mike pence dass man doch die
entscheidung letztlich jedem amerikaner
selber überlassen müsse also freiheit
sei das viel wichtigere als sie ihm
vorzuschreiben was er zu tun oder zu
lassen hat ich glaube dieses argument
ging dann ein stück weit in die lehrer
war kammerherr ist klar gemacht es geht
ja gar nicht darum die um die frage ob
man menschen etwas vorschreibt sondern
ob man ein beispiel gibt ob man menschen
eine bessere lösung vorlebt und da hätte
natürlich das weiße haus gelegenheit
dazu gehabt flankiert wurde die debatte
auch mit neuen meldungen dass
mittlerweile 34 personen aus dem weißen
haus mit corona infiziert sind also es
ist ein ganz klarer hotspot insofern
leidet da zu diesem thema jedenfalls
doch auch die glaubwürdigkeit dieser
regierung
dazu passt auch die frage einer userin
sophie hat man fragt über facebook das
ende der debatte wir haben es gesehen da
kommen die partner jeweils zusammen
von von fans und harris der mann von
camilla harris trägt keine strickmaske
die frau von patrick keine sie fragt ob
das überhaupt so sein darf dass sie da
ohne maske hin dass und ich möchte die
frage noch anschließen
ob man damit auch eine botschaft wieder
senden wollte es gab eine ganz klare
ansage vorher dass jeder der im saal
ismus maske tragen ausser eben
moderatorin und die beiden kontrahenten
ganz offenbar hat sich carroll pence
nicht daran gehalten sie ist ohne maske
dann auf die bühne gekommen während 3m
hofft der mann von kemmler harris maske
getragen hat vorher war sogar
angekündigt worden wer die maske ab
zieht der wirt des saales verwiesen wo
war es ganz am ende da konnte man glaube
ich niemanden mehr des saales verweisen
aber auch das sendet wieder ein signal
nach draußen ins land und ich glaube
dass da eine fehlkalkulation beim team
tram pence vorhanden ist sie glauben
ganz offenbar dass das ein positives
signal ist dass das punkte bringt im
wahlkampf ich glaube das gegenteil ist
der fall das sagen uns auch die umfragen
dass die meisten amerikaner der meinung
sind dass dieses verhalten des weißen
hauses des präsidenten vorweg eigentlich
unverantwortlich ist
ein anderes thema das in den usa
hochgekocht ist muss man in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten schon
sagen ist das thema rassismus und
polizeigewalt die black live metlife
matter bewegung hat zehntausende auf die
straße gebracht und die nation auch sehr
gespalten muss man sagen die einen
werfen ihm vor er diese da öl ins feuer
die anderen feiern ihn dafür
und wir schauen mal was die beiden
kandidaten zu diesem themenkomplex zu
sagen hatten
das bringt mich zu den acht minuten und
46 sekunden die amerika miterlebt hat
während der ein mann gequält und getötet
wurde
unter dem knie eines uniformierten
polizeibeamten die menschen unseres
landes egal welcher herkunft welchen
alters welchen geschlechts sie
marschieren schulter an schulter arm in
arm um für das ideal der
gleichberechtigung zu kämpfen
wenn es um george floyd geht es gibt
keine entschuldigung dafür was ihm
passiert ist aber es gibt auch keine
entschuldigung für die randale und
plünderungen
die folgten dazu passt eine user frage
die ich gleich anschließen möchte an die
töne bevor ich meine fragen dann wieder
stelle kommt von angeber auf youtube
welche programme stellen sich beide
gegner hinsichtlich straffällig
gewordener minderheiten und einer
potentiellen reform des justizwesens vor
emma
also da gibt es bei der tramp kampagne
oder weil wahlkampfteam eigentlich nur
das was schon passiert ist nämlich die
justiz strafrechtsreform die bereits
stattgefunden hat es gibt keine weiteren
pläne also wir hatten da ein wenig im
dunkeln war schlicht und ergreifend das
wahl programm von 2016 einfach normal
übernommen worden ist gibt nichts neues
dazu außer dass donald trump und mike
bands sagen recht und ordnung
durchsetzen das ist das wichtigste und
der polizei den rücken stärken auf der
anderen seite so es gibt ein
detailliertes programm und das lautet
nicht die polizei abschaffen sondern das
hat carola harris auch noch mal ganz
klar gesagt dass gewalt egal von welcher
seite sie ausgeht verurteilt und
verfolgt werden muss
sie hat auch klar gemacht es geht nicht
um die abschaffung der polizei sondern
um eine reform
und sie hat eben auch gesagt dass es
tatsächlich so etwas wie systemischen
rassismus in den usa gibt das bedeutet
dass man bessere ausbildung auch braucht
für die polizei so sagt sie ganz klar
auch im justizsystem gibt es eben
vorurteile gegenüber minderheiten in der
gesellschaft und das vor allen dingen im
strafrecht system für sehr sehr kleine
vergehen schon sehr drakonische strafen
verhängt werden
auch da hat sie einige punkte
angesprochen dass beispielsweise der
besitz von kleinstmengen von marihuana
beispielsweise oder überhaupt von
marihuana legalisiert werden soll
das gibt in einigen bundesstaaten regeln
nach denen die menschen für einen
längeren zeitraum eingesperrt werden
also auch das ein versuch zumindest mal
in diesem bereich menschen ein stück
weit aus den vorurteilen im strafrecht
system oder vor den vorteilen im
amerikanischen strafrecht system zu
schützen war bei diesen themenkomplex
auch ihre frühere funktion als
generalstaatsanwältin in kalifornien
thema ja das war es aber nicht nur bei
diesem sondern also bei diesem war es
natürlich thema weil mike pence zum
thema gemacht hat er hat ganz klar
gesagt dass ihr verhalten damals als
staatsanwältin im grunde genommen
ausweist dass sie auch gegen schwarze
also gegen minderheiten mit aller
schärfe sogar mit überzogener schafe wie
er behauptet vorgegangen ist das werfen
ja in der
da hat einige innerhalb der
demokratischen partei auch vor aber das
macht ja interessanterweise dann die
pläne von mike von von joe biden und
camilla harris noch glaubwürdiger weil
sie ja bewiesen hat dass sie eben nicht
gegen gesetze und ordnung ist sondern
gegen sei im gegenteil auch gesetz und
ordnung durchsetzen will und auch kann
wichtig ist glaube ich auch noch mal in
diesem wie auch in vielen anderen
punkten das was ich vorhin angesprochen
habe inwieweit fakten nicht stimmten bzw
falsche behauptungen und lügen im raum
stand und auch da wurde sehr klar die
vorgeschichte von camilla harris als
staatsanwältin sorgte dafür dass sie an
einigen stellen sehr klar gemacht hat
dass so dass mike pence tatsächlich
möglich filme ein beispiel nennen wenn
es um die steuern geht da sagt er
die steuersenkung im jahr 2017 habe
jeder familie in amerika 4000 dollar im
jahr mehr geld in der tasche zurück
gelassen mit anderen worten so viel
haben sie weniger steuern bezahlt das
ist nachweislich falsch das hat auch
kamen daher ist gesagt und man kann in
der tat die zahlen auch jederzeit
nachschlagen es sind 500 dollar die die
menschen tatsächlich mehr in der tasche
hatten
oder sind eigentlich nur ein anstieg von
also mehr geld in der tasche von 0,4
prozent während in den vorjahren
eigentlich immer die menschen pro jahr
etwa 0,6 prozent pro familie mehr in der
tasche hatten
gegen schluss der debatte ging es um ein
thema das auch für uns in deutschland
interessant ist da ging es um die
außenpolitik da hat donald trump in den
vergangenen jahren jahr international
ziemlich viel porzellan zerschlagen mit
einem sagen wir mal nicht sehr
multilateral angehauchtem kurs um es
diplomatisch so sagen wir hören auch
hier zunächst mal in die routine rein
was wir bei donald trump gesehen haben
ist er hat unsere freunde verraten und
stattdessen diktatoren überall auf der
welt regelrecht umarmt zum beispiel
russland es geht um unsere freunde bei
der nato er hat abkommen aufgekündigt
auch das atom abkommen mit dem iran
das hat uns in eine situation gebracht
in der wehr weniger sicher sind wir
stehen zu unseren verbündeten aber wir
hatten auch forderungen die nato trägt
jetzt mehr zur gemeinsamen verteidigung
bei dank präsident trump außerdem hat
fand das amerikanische militär
losgeschickt unsere soldaten zerstörten
das kalifat brachten ihren anführer al
bagdadi zu fall und zwar ohne
amerikanische opfer auch hier wurde mit
vier vorwürfen gearbeitet mit viel
angstmacherei auch immer was heißt das
konkret
naja ich glaube beide seiten haben
daraus gestrichen was sie was im kurs
stimmt also sowohl die vorwürfe von
camilla harris stimmen dass tatsächlich
diktatoren sich durch den amerikanischen
präsidenten er ermutigt fühlen ich
glaube zu dieser analyse kann man ganz
klar kommen was wladimir putin oder war
auch was präsident sie in china angeht
umgekehrt stimmt genauso was marc penz
gesagt hat das eben unter donald trump
das kalifat besiegt worden ist das unter
donald trump eben auch terroristen
gejagt und tatsächlich daneben auch
getötet worden sind also er hat eine
reihe auch von außenpolitischen
sicherheitspolitischen erfolge
aufzuweisen
aber es ist ja eigentlich das gute an
der inhaltlichen debatte dass dann die
menschen draußen am bildschirm sehen
können was haben die einzelnen
vorzuweisen was stimmt was stimmt nicht
und auf der basis die entscheidungen zu
fällen für mich sagen wir mal ist
interessant dass ausgerechnet das
offenbar wichtigste ist diskutierte
thema in den sozialen medien gar nicht
so die inhalte sind über die wir jetzt
hier geredet haben sondern tatsächlich
die fliege die sich für zwei minuten und
drei sekunden
auf my pants niedergelassen hatte das
heißt im umkehrschluss er hat eigentlich
das nicht erreicht was er brauchte mike
pence hatte den auftrag das blatt zu
wenden denn in den umfragen sieht es
sehr schlecht aus für donald trump und
mike pence und er hätte hier einen sehr
klaren großen sieg davon tragen müssen
um vielleicht zu einem einer
revitalisierung des wahlkampfes
beizutragen und das ist ganz
offensichtlich heute nacht nicht
gelungen da sind wir schon bei der
analyse wer hat wie punkten können für
donald trump den amtierenden us
präsidenten liegt es auf der hand er
twitterte noch während des duells harris
sei eine ausrutscher maschine dagegen
schlage sich fans großartig das nicht
natürlich in der natur der sache dass
der präsident das so sieht wie sehen es
denn die amerikaner die sind hier mal
recht schnell dabei dann auch
blitzumfragen kurz nach den debatten zu
generieren wohin schlägt das pendel aus
also die blitzumfragen sagen klarer
punktsieg für camilla harris teilweise
sogar sehr deutlich 59 zu 38 prozent
sagen dass camilla harris die debatte
gewonnen hat bei einer blitzumfrage von
cnn
ich glaube das muss man immer mit
vorsicht genießen interessanter ist wenn
man die einzelnen stimmen hört von
zuhörern zuschauern die das duell
verfolgt haben die ihre
schlussfolgerungen dann auch in worte
fassen und auch da eigentlich sehr klar
und deutlich dass camilla harris den
punkt sieg davon getragen hat heißt im
umkehrschluss das wird ein sehr schwerer
wahlkampf jetzt weiter für dafür für
donald trump und für mike pence man kann
sagen ihr wahlkampf liegt ein stück weit
in trümmern
und deswegen will dort auch unbedingt
wieder selber raus hat angekündigt
nächste woche vielleicht schon nach
pittsburgh pennsylvania zu gehen eine
neue wahlkampf kundgebung durchzuführen
was aus sicht von medizinischen experten
natürlich wahnsinnig ist wenn er doch
gerade erst das corona virus sich mit
dem corona virus angesteckt hatte aber
ich möchte enden mit der frage einer
nutzerin über youtube fragt julia watt
in welche richtung bewegen sich die
amerikaner bezüglich ihrer politischen
einstellung liberal oder eher
konservativ
aber schwer zu sagen dass wenn man
wahlergebnis ablesen können aber ich
wage meine wilde prognose und ich sage
nach jetzigen stand wenn jetzt wahl wäre
am heutigen tag oder morgen dann glaube
ich würden wir einen erdrutschsieg für
joe biden sehen weil doch mehr menschen
eher in richtung progressiv und
liberaler tendieren in den usa und vor
allen dingen ein wechsel wollen ob sich
das hält bis zur wahl am dritten
november
das müssen wir noch ein stück weit
abwarten ein highlight eben
us-präsidentschaftswahlkampf das war
heute nacht das duell der vize
kandidatin kamera harris gegen mike
pence wir haben in den vergangenen
minuten mal geschaut was die beiden zu
sagen hatten wie sie sich positioniert
haben wie sie sich geschlagen haben
elmar herzlichen dank nach washington
und liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
auch an euch danke schön für das
interesse wer die debatte noch einmal
ganz nachschauen wollen auf der zdf
mediathek haben wir sie für sie
bereitgestellt wir wünschen noch einen
schönen donnerstag macht's gut